Qu'est ce que la vie?
En voilà une belle question
philosophique et scientifique.
Qu'est ce qui fait la différence entre
ce qui est vivant et ce qui ne l'est pas?
Ce qui est marrant c'est, qu'en pratique,
un enfant de 10 ans n'aurait pas de mal
à vous donner des réponses.
Montrez-lui des photos et il vous dira
qu'un chat et un arbre sont vivant
mais pas un caillou ou une trompette.
Ce qui est vivant ben… ça se voit non?
Enfin est-ce que c'est si simple?
Prenons quelques cas un peu tordus,
ce corail par exemple, eh bien malgré son
apparence de gros cailloux,
il s'agit bien d'un organisme vivant,
et ça n'est même pas une plante hein,
il fait partie du règne animal.
Et la levure chimique?
Alors non la levure chimique
ça n'est pas vivant,
c'est juste un mélange de
bicarbonate de soude et d'acide citrique.
Par contre la levure de boulanger,
et bien ça, c'est vivant,
si vous en observez au microscope,
vous verrez des cellules,
les levures sont en effet
des micro-organismes unicellulaires
que l'on classe avec les champignons.
Un chat, un concombre, du corail
et de la levure de boulanger,
malgré leurs apparences extérieures
si différentes,
tous sont composés de cellules vivantes.
Et si on était capable de plonger
jusqu'à l'intérieur de ces cellules,
de nager dedans,
on aurait probablement un peu de mal
à faire la différence entre
ces différents organismes,
car toutes les cellules vivantes partagent,
en effet, un certain nombre de traits communs.
Si leur taille peut varier beaucoup
d'un organisme à un autre,
et au sein du même organisme,
toutes les cellules vivantes sont
délimitées de la même façon,
par une membrane faite
d'une double couche de lipides.
C'est une première caractéristique
commune à tous les êtres vivants.
Ce qu'on trouve à l'intérieur
de ces cellules
va évidemment dépendre de l'espèce,
mais il existe un certain nombre de processus
que l'on retrouve à l'identique
que l'on parle d'un humain,
d'un concombre ou d'une levure.
Les cellules ont par exemple besoin
d'énergie pour fonctionner
et dans l'ensemble du monde vivant
cette énergie est stockée
par la même molécule: l'ATP.
L'ATP, l'adénosine triphosphate
de son petit nom,
c'est une molécule qu'on appelle parfois
la "monnaie énergétique" de la cellule,
chez tous les êtres vivants,
elle est au cœur du métabolisme
en étant sans cesse transportée,
consommée et régénérée
par les différents processus à l’œuvre
dans une cellule.
À cet instant dans votre corps,
l'ensemble de vos cellules contiennent
au total quelques centaines de grammes d'ATP,
mais au cours d'une journée
c'est l'équivalent de votre poids en ATP
qui sera consommé et produit par votre corps.
L'ATP et son utilisation
dans le métabolisme,
voilà donc un autre trait que l'on retrouve
chez tous les êtres vivants qu'on connaît.
Et puis bien sûr, un autre point commun
à l'ensemble du monde vivant,
c'est évidemment l'ADN.
Cette longue molécule sert de support
pour les gênes
grâce à la séquence de ses bases,
les fameuses A, G, T, C.
Grâce à cet alphabet rudimentaire,
l'ADN permet le stockage
de l'information génétique.
Dans une cellule de concombre comme dans une
cellule d'Henry Cavill,
l'ADN est constituée exactement
de la même façon,
et on retrouve la même machinerie cellulaire
permettant notamment sa réplication et son
utilisation pour la fabrication des protéines.
En effet dans une cellule, il existe des
milliers de protéines différentes
ayant chacune une fonction spécifique,
chaque cellule doit donc savoir
comment fabriquer précisément
les protéines qui lui sont utiles.
Et c'est là que l'ADN sert en quelque sorte
de "plan de montage".
Une protéine est toujours fabriquée
comme une chaîne de briques élémentaires
qu'on appelle les acides aminés.
Il en existe vingt différents qui portent
des petits noms:
leucine, alanine, cystéine, etc.,
et le plan de montage d'une protéine donnée,
c'est donc simplement la liste des acides
aminés qu'il faut enchaîner pour la fabriquer.
Pour faire le lien entre l'ADN et la liste
d'acides aminés qui composent une protéine,
il y a un ensemble remarquable de règles
qu'on appelle le "code génétique".
Le code génétique, c'est ce tableau qui
indique comment,
à partir de la lecture de la suite
des bases de l'ADN,
on peut connaître la liste des acides aminés
à enchaîner pour faire une protéine donnée.
On lit les bases de l'ADN
par groupes de trois,
et chaque groupe indique quel acide aminé
ajouter à la chaîne.
Et ce tableau de conversion est le même chez
tous les êtres vivants,
de la levure jusqu'à vous.
C'est remarquable non?
Avec tous ces points communs,
on peut dire qu'on a notre définition,
la vie c'est tout ce qui est fait de cellules
dans lesquelles on trouve de l'ADN
et pour lesquels le métabolisme
utilise l'ATP.
Sauf que, comme toujours,
quand on essaye de formaliser
une définition d'un phénomène naturel,
on fini par trouver des choses
qui sont à la frontière.
Prenons les virus, contrairement à ce
qu'on pourrait penser,
en regardant une de ces
représentations graphiques,
les virus ne sont pas des cellules,
la structure que l'on voit
sur les images de ce genre
est ce qu'on appelle une capside,
et elle est faite de protéines.
Et à l'intérieur des virus, on trouve
uniquement de l'ADN ou de l'ARN,
pas de machinerie cellulaire,
pas de métabolisme.
Et le principe d'un virus,
c'est justement qu'il va devoir infecter
une cellule d'un autre organisme
et emprunter sa machinerie,
pour y faire passer son ADN.
Alors est-ce que les virus doivent
être considérés comme vivants?
Eh bien la question fait débat entre les
spécialistes,
on pourrait dire que oui,
car ils ont de l'information génétique
sous forme d'ADN ou d'ARN
mais on pourrait dire non,
car ils n'ont pas de métabolisme
et de capacité autonome à se reproduire.
Et encore on peut trouver des exemples
toujours plus étonnants
comme les viroïdes qui sont juste
des morceaux d'ARN
tout seuls sans capside pour les entourer.
Ou bien les prions qui sont
de simples protéines
ayant une capacité à contaminer
d'autres protéines en les déformant.
J'en avais déjà parlé dans un épisode
précédent sur le sujet,
si ça vous intéresse vous pouvez aller
jeter un œil.
Donc notre définition de la vie
qui paraissait bien,
on pourrait facilement la questionner
sur la base de ces exemples.
Mais dans le fond,
pourquoi est-ce qu'on aurait besoin
d'une définition précise de la vie?
Eh bien faire l'exercice de réfléchir à une
définition de la vie,
peut avoir un impact sur la façon dont on
approche la question des origines de la vie.
En effet aujourd'hui on ne sait toujours pas
comment la vie est apparue sur terre
il y a trois ou quatre milliards d'années.
Qu'est-ce qui est le plus essentiel?
La présence d'ADN et d'ARN?
Le métabolisme avec de l'ATP?
Les cellules délimitées par
une membrane de lipides?
Suivant l'importance que l'on donne
à ces critères
on n'envisagera pas la question des origines
de la vie de la même façon.
La vie est-elle d'abord apparue dans
de l'eau douce,
qui semblerait pus propices à la formation
de vésicules de lipides?
Ou bien dans des argiles qui sont adaptées
pour catalyser certaines
réactions biochimiques?
Ou encore au fond de l'océan dans des sources
hydrothermales idéales pour le métabolisme?
Chacune de ces hypothèses tend à plus mettre
l'accent sur l'un ou l'autre des aspects
qui caractérisent la vie
telle qu'on la connaît.
Mais au delà de la recherche des origines
de la vie sur Terre,
il existe bien sûr un autre domaine
pour lequel une définition de la vie est
absolument essentielle,
il s'agit de "l'astrobiologie".
La discipline qui cherche à savoir
si la vie existe ailleurs que sur Terre
et comment on pourrait la détecter.
Quand on essaye d'imaginer à quoi pourrait
ressembler une forme de vie extraterrestre,
on tombe assez vite dans un travers classique,
on se la représente comme une version un peu
modifiée de la vie
telle qu'on la connaît sur Terre.
De la végétation verte, des animaux
quadrupèdes, des êtres intelligents bipèdes.
Bref, c'est en gros la vie sur Terre
qui aurait juste évolué un peu différemment.
Et pourtant rien ne nous oblige à imaginer
la vie ailleurs,
comme un simple copier-coller
de la vie sur Terre.
D'ailleurs si on s'intéresse
à ce que j'ai listé
comme des essentiels de la vie
telle qu'on la connaît,
on peut facilement imaginer des variations
biochimiques importantes.
Prenons les acides aminés
qui constituent nos protéines.
Le terme acides aminés en général,
désigne n'importe quelles molécules
fabriquées selon un canevas précis
qui est le suivant:
un atome de carbone qu'on représente
souvent en position centrale,
relié à un hydrogène,
un groupe NH2, l'amine,
et un groupe COOH l'acide,
d'où le nom: acide aminé.
Et sur la quatrième liaison du carbone,
eh ben on met un peu ce qu'on veut,
Enfin, ce qui chimiquement peut aller
à cet endroit là.
On appelle ça un radical.
Si comme radical vous mettez simplement
un hydrogène,
vous avez l'acide aminé qu'on appelle
la glycine.
Avec un groupe CH3 vous avez l'alanine,
un CH2SH la, cystéine etc.
Des acides aminés qui apparaissent
dans le code génétique
et qui sont donc utilisés pour synthétiser
des protéines dans le monde vivant,
on l'a dit, il y en a 20.
Mais chimiquement on peut en imaginer
plein d'autres,
Il suffit de faire varier
ce qu'on met comme radical.
Artificiellement on sait d'ailleurs
en synthétiser plusieurs centaines d'autres.
Alors pourquoi ne pas imaginer
des formes de vie
qui se baseraient sur certains
de ces autres acides aminés?
C'est d'autant plus attirant comme hypothèse
que l'on sait que beaucoup
de ces acides aminés
sont assez faciles à produire
dans des conditions naturelles.
On en a trouvé notamment dans des expériences
qui reconstituent les conditions
physico-chimiques
qui régnaient sur Terre
il y a 4 milliards d'années,
comme dans la fameuse expérience
de Miller-Urey.
Et encore mieux, certain
de ces acides aminés exotiques
ont été retrouvés dans des météorites
comme la météorite de Murchison,
tombée en Australie en 1969.
On y a, par exemple identifié
les acides aminés
qu'on appelle la Norvaline,
l'isovaline et la Sarcosine,
oui, oui ça existe, la Sarcosine!
Aucun de ces acides aminés ne fait partie
de la "liste des vingt",
mais on pourrait très bien imaginer
des formes de vie alternatives
qui les utilisent pour
la synthèse des protéines.
Toutes ces variations autour
de la biochimie de la vie,
pourraient très bien exister.
Mais peut-être qu'on est encore
trop conservateur,
trop influencé par la vie
telle qu'on la connaît,
et s'il fallait imaginer utiliser carrément
des réactions chimiques différentes.
Bon, déjà vous le savez la vie sur Terre
est basée sur l'eau.
L'eau sert de solvant,
c'est-à-dire de milieu liquide dans lequel
peuvent se dissoudre les différentes molécules,
ce qui leur permet de se rencontrer
et de réagir.
Mais on pourrait imaginer d'autres solvants.
J'en avais parlé dans la vidéo
sur l'eau justement,
d'autres molécules comme l'ammoniac NH3
et le méthane CH4,
pourraient dans certaines conditions,
servir aussi de solvants et donc de milieux
de base à de nouvelles formes de vie.
On peut penser notamment à Titan,
c'est une lune de Saturne qui fait à peu
près la moitié de la terre en diamètre,
et qui possède des océans,
des nuages et des rivières.
Mais au lieu d'être de l'eau,
c'est du méthane liquide.
Il y a sur Titan tout un cycle
du méthane
comme nous, nous avons sur Terre
un cycle de l'eau.
Et ce serait assez tentant d'imaginer
y trouver des organismes
chimiquement très différents
de ce qu'on connaît.
Pour pousser encore plus loin,
on peut remarquer une chose étonnante,
la quasi-totalité des molécules
qui interviennent dans la vie sur terre,
sont constituées de seulement six éléments:
carbone, hydrogène, oxygène,
Azote, phosphore et soufre,
on les appelle les "CHOMPS".
Et pour fabriquer tout ce dont on a parlé,
les protéines, l'ADN, l'ARN, les glucides
et les lipides,
ces six éléments là suffisent.
Mais si on imaginait des biochimies
alternatives avec d'autres éléments,
après tout il y en a plus d'une centaine
pourquoi se limiter à ces six-là?
Alors pour nous aider à visualiser ça,
on peut se servir du tableau de Mendeleev.
Le voici avec la position des six éléments
dont on a parlé, les CHOMPS.
Ce tableau, vous savez qu'on l'appelle aussi
le tableau "périodique" des éléments,
et la raison c'est que dans une même
colonne du tableau,
on trouve des éléments ayant un comportement
chimique comparable.
La première colonne: ce sont les alcalins,
la deuxième: les alcalino-téreux,
la dernière: les gaz rares etc.
Et donc en général, quand vous prenez
un élément,
l'élément situé en dessous de lui,
aura de bonnes chances de former
des liaisons chimiques similaires.
Et donc pour trouver
des alternatives aux CHOMPS,
on peut peut-être aller piocher
dans les mêmes colonnes,
par exemple juste en dessous du soufre,
on a le sélénium.
C'est un élément peu abondant mais
qui chimiquement est très proche du soufre.
Pourquoi pas une forme de vie
qui l'utiliserait?
D'ailleurs de façon intéressante, c'est déjà
un peu ce que fait la vie sur Terre.
Je vous ai dit qu'il n'y avait
que 20 acides aminés
qui entraient dans la composition
initiale des protéines,
et bien il y en a en fait un 21ème
qui est la sélénocystéine.
C'est un acide aminé en tout point
identique à la cystéine,
mais où l'atome de soufre a été remplacé
par un atome de sélénium,
et comme chimiquement ces deux là
sont très proches, eh bien ça fonctionne.
Alors cet acide aminé non standard
est assez rare
et on ne le retrouve même pas chez
tous les êtres vivants,
mais par exemple chez l'homme on connaît
une cinquantaine de protéines qui l'utilisent,
comme quoi même la vie sur Terre
arrive à faire des variations
de ses ingrédients de base.
Alors revenons au tableau périodique.
En dessous du phosphore regardez:
on trouve l'arsenic,
sa position nous dit que chimiquement,
l'arsenic et le phosphore peuvent
avoir des comportements analogues.
Et c'est d'ailleurs ça qui rend
l'arsenic si dangereux.
En effet le phosphore est un élément clé
du fonctionnement de l'ATP
et de la structure de l'ADN.
Et donc, si un atome d'arsenic vient prendre
la place d'un atome de phosphore,
cela peut perturber le fonctionnement
du métabolisme
ou encore la réplication de l'ADN.
C'est pour cela que l'arsenic est à la fois
un poison et un cancérigène.
Mais si une nouvelle forme de vie
se basait complètement sur l'arsenic
à la place du phosphore,
chimiquement on se dit
que ça pourrait marcher.
C'est d'ailleurs ce que certains ont cru
découvrir dans une bactérie,
il y a une dizaine d'années.
Alors la nouvelle a fait grand bruit,
mais la découverte a été contestée
et finalement la publication scientifique
a été retirée.
La vie à l'arsenic, pas forcément sur Terre
mais sur une autre planète pourquoi pas?
Encore plus exotique: en dessous du carbone
dans le tableau périodique,
il y a le silicium.
Alors le carbone, c'est vraiment l'élément
clé de la biochimie
car avec ses quatre liaisons, il peut former
tout un tas de molécules complexes
et il est donc à la base de toute
la chimie organique du vivant.
Et c'est aussi grâce aux liaisons du carbone
que l'on peut produire des matières plastiques.
Les plastiques sont en effet de longues
chaînes à base de carbone,
qui répètent sans cesse la même
structure élémentaire.
C'est ce qu'on appelle des polymères.
Mais le silicium avec ses quatre
liaisons potentielles,
peut dans une certaine mesure,
jouer un rôle analogue à celui du carbone.
C'est notamment ce qui permet
industriellement
de fabriquer les polymères
qu'on appelle des silicones,
qui sont des plastiques ayant
des propriétés différentes
de ceux basés uniquement sur le carbone.
Alors allons-y pourquoi pas une forme
de vie entièrement basée sur le silicium?
Après tout, il s'agit d'un des éléments
les plus abondants
sur une planète rocheuse comme la Terre,
et certains organismes vivants savent
d'ailleurs déjà l'utiliser,
c'est le cas par exemple des diatomées
qui sont des unicellulaires
capables de se constituer de magnifiques
coquilles microscopique de SiO2, la silice.
Elles se font en gros des coquilles
en verre naturel.
Si on essaie d'imaginer une forme
de vie basée sur le silicium,
ça voudrait dire que des organismes
pourraient métaboliser
des molécules à base de silicium
et respireraient en rejetant non pas du CO2,
mais du SiO2,
elles expireraient du verre donc…
Bon beh, pourquoi pas?
Alors parmi tous les gens
qui se sont amusés à essayer
de définir la vie de la façon
la plus large possible,
il y a évidemment la NASA.
Et ce, tout particulièrement depuis le début
des missions en direction de mars
et le lancement des sondes Viking en 1975.
On comprend l'importance de la question hein!
Si l'ambition de ces missions
est de rechercher la présence de vie,
on a plutôt intérêt à avoir une bonne
définition de ce qu'on appelle la vie,
car évidemment ça va conditionner les
instruments qu'on va embarquer,
les analyses qu'on voudra faire etc.
Dans les années 90, un groupe de travail
de la NASA
a justement proposé une nouvelle définition
de la vie
qui a le mérite d'être à la fois suffisamment
large et tout de même utilisable.
la vie, ce serait:
Dans cette définition tous
les mots sont importants:
Le mot "système" d'abord,
il montre bien que la vie ce n'est pas
tellement un truc ici ou là,
c'est avant tout un système
de composants en interaction.
Si on prend une cellule et qu'on considère
indépendamment chaque molécule,
aucune de ces molécules en particulier
n'est vivante,
c'est le système dans son ensemble qui l'est.
Le mot "chimique" ensuite,
alors là on reste suffisamment large sans
supposer un rôle prépondérant
pour par exemple, l'eau ou le carbone,
très bien.
"Auto-entretenue",
attention ça ne veut pas dire qu'un système
vivant est capable de mouvement perpétuel.
Mais qu'il sait puiser dans son
environnement les ressources nécessaires
pour assurer son maintien,
au moins provisoirement.
Et enfin la partie la plus intrigante,
"capable d'évolution darwinienne",
c'est vrai qu'une des choses qui est
caractéristique de la vie sur Terre,
c'est bien la notion d'évolution
au moyen de la sélection naturelle,
ce qu'avait compris Darwin sans avoir
découvert le mécanisme chimique détaillé
qui se cachait derrière.
Depuis Darwin, on a compris que
dans la vie sur Terre,
l'évolution est rendue possible par l'ADN,
c'est lui qui porte les gènes,
c'est à dire l'information indispensable
à la notion d'évolution.
Mais la définition de la NASA
laisse évidemment la porte largement ouverte
et permet d'autres mécanismes
que celui basé sur l'ADN.
C'est d'ailleurs un exercice intéressant
de se demander
de quoi on aurait besoin, chimiquement
pour avoir quelque chose de similaire
à du stockage d'information génétique.
Pour qu'il y ait une évolution darwinienne.
Le support chimique de l'information
doit posséder deux propriétés:
la réplication et les erreurs.
Prenez l'ADN,
la raison pour laquelle cette molécule
permet les mécanismes d'hérédité,
c'est qu'elle est réplicable,
il est chimiquement possible
de recopier un brin d'ADN
pour le passer à sa descendance
par exemple.
Mais paradoxalement, pour que l'évolution
darwinienne puisse avoir lieu,
il ne faut pas que cette copie soit
absolument parfaite,
il faut aussi des erreurs,
sinon l'information serait toujours
copiée à l'identique
et les organismes n'évolueraient jamais.
Ce qui permet l'évolution darwinienn,
ce sont justement ces erreurs de copie,
les mutations, qui de temps en temps,
donneront des descendants mieux adaptés
à leur environnement
et qui seront donc favorisés
par la sélection naturelle.
Pour stocker comme ça une grande quantité
d'information sur un support chimique,
il faut évidemment des molécules
très grandes,
c'est ce qui se passe avec l'ADN et l'ARN,
elles sont constituées d'un assemblage
répété de blocs élémentaires,
ce sont donc des polymères.
Je vous l'ai dit des polymères,
on en connaît plein,
tous les plastiques dont le nom commence
par poly quelque chose
ce sont des polymères qui peuvent être
très longs.
Alors est-ce que n'importe lequel
de ces polymères
pourrait convenir pour stocker
de l'information génétique?
Eh bien probablement pas,
car il y a une chose remarquable
avec la molécule d'ADN,
si vous prenez votre ADN et celui
d'un concombre, on l'a dit,
la structure globale est la même,
mais le détail est évidemment très différent,
la suite des bases A G T C qui les
constituent ne va pas du tout être identique,
sinon vous seriez un concombre.
Et pourtant sur le plan physico-chimique,
votre ADN et celui d'un concombre
se comportent de manière parfaitement
similaire,
ils sont traités dans les mêmes conditions
par là-même machinerie cellulaire.
En gros ça veut dire que l'ADN
est une molécule
dont on peut changer carrément des atomes
sans pour autant affecter ses propriétés
physico-chimiques globales.
D'habitude ça ne marche pas ça,
si vous prenez une molécule
et que vous changez certains atomes,
ben vous allez récupérer une molécule
qui n'est pas la même
et qui physiquement et chimiquement
va peut-être se comporter de façon
totalement différente.
Qu'est-ce qui fait cette sorte de
stabilité de l'ADN,
le fait que quelle que soit
la séquence des bases,
il se comporte à l'identique?
Eh bien, d'après le biologiste
Steven Benner,
l'ingrédient clé ce sont
les groupes phosphate
que l'on retrouve dans le squelette de l'ADN
et, en particulier le fait que ces phosphates
soient chargés négativement.
Cette chaîne de charges négatives
dans le squelette
joue un rôle tellement dominant
dans la détermination des interactions
physiques de la molécule d'ADN
que, peu importe les bases qu'on y attache,
la molécule réagit de la même façon.
Et cela a mené Steven Benner à proposer
que pour stocker de l'information génétique,
l'idéal c'était d'avoir une molécule
qui soit un polymère
dont les blocs élémentaires
portent des charges,
ce qu'on appelle un polyélectrolyte.
Donc pour lui, pour identifier
de la vie ailleurs,
un système capable d'évolution darwinienne,
il faut chercher des traces
de polyélectrolytes.
Steven Benner a d'ailleurs lui-même
essayé d'en fabriquer de façon synthétique
pour démontrer comment créer des alternatives
à l'ADN qui ne soient pas de l'ADN.
C'est ainsi qu'en 2019,
il a publié un exemple de polyélectrolyte
pouvant servir de support d'information
et comportant huit bases
au lieu des 4 dont on a l'habitude.
Avec toutes ces considérations,
on peut se dire qu'on a maintenant une
définition de la vie
qui nous permettent de rechercher
des choses de façon suffisamment large,
sans tomber dans le piège
de chercher quelque chose
qui ressemble trop à la vie sur Terre
telle qu'on la connaît.
Mais si on était encore trop restrictif,
et si la vie pouvait prendre des formes
qui nous échappent complètement,
qui s'affranchissent carrément de la chimie
telle qu'on l'envisage?
En 1964 alors que la NASA
se posait ses premières questions
sur "comment définir la vie pour l'identifier".
Le chimiste James Lovelock leur avait dit:
"Si j'étais vous pour trouver de la vie,
je chercherais des réductions d'entropie"
Ah l'entropie!
C'est une notion qu'on associe
souvent au désordre
et dont le deuxième principe
de la thermodynamique
nous dit qu'elle ne peut qu'augmenter,
dans l'univers le désordre va croissant.
Et pourtant on dirait que l'émergence
de la vie s'affranchit de ça,
des structures de plus en plus ordonnées
de plus en plus organisées,
de plus en plus complexes.
Est-ce que la vie va à l'encontre
des lois de la thermodynamique?
J'avais un tout petit peu évoqué
ces questions
dans mon épisode sur l'énergie et l'entropie.
et j'avais promis de vous faire une suite
sur la thermodynamique de la vie.
Eh bien voilà, les bases sont posées
et dans le prochain épisode
on se demandera donc
comment on peut définir la notion de vie
à partir de considérations thermodynamiques.
Merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo,
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner
si vous aimez ce contenu
pour être sûrs de ne rien rater,
vous pouvez aussi retrouver les actualités
de la chaîne sur facebook et sur twitter,
et puis on se retrouve bientôt pour la
suite de cette exploration de la vie
– Sous-titrage: Le Crayon d'Oreille -